what is a cloud shell and how can a
cloud shell
enable rapid cloud resource management
and development
from anywhere i'm nathan heckman from
ibm cloud
and i'm going to answer that today so
let's say you just finished developing
an exciting new app
and you decide to go on a well-earned
vacation
so this is you
and you're sitting on a beach enjoying
yourself when
all of a sudden you get a call from your
boss
and they're not happy because that
application just went down in production
so what do you do you don't have your
work computer with you on the beach
enter cloud shell
you log into one of the hotel computers
you open up a web browser
and with cloud shell you're able to fix
the app in no time at all
so that you can go back to enjoying your
vacation
and your boss is happy so
let's compare some of the benefits of
cloud shell
with working with your local machine
in a shell so
with your local machine there's some
limitations
right so first of all inherently you're
going to use
more resources on your cpu and memory
it's just more resource intensive
because it's actually on your machine
you also need to worry about installing
software
and updating software
and tools this can be annoying right
everyone's been there where you're
constantly prompted for updates and you
need to keep things
to the latest version in order to keep
them working
and finally if you're working with a
cloud provider
you're always getting logged out
so you have to manage your
authentication your tokens etc
well with cloud shell
[Music]
it's a consistent environment
what does this mean so first of all
all of your cloud authentication is
taken care of
so you're securely authenticated to your
cloud provider
without doing anything
also you don't need to worry about
installing
tools everything is already installed
and ready to go
and finally maybe most helpful
is there's no need to update
so everything's on the latest version
and you can get started and get right to
work
another benefit of cloud shells is that
you can
manage your cloud
so what can you manage well your
resources
and infrastructure
you can manage your applications
and you can view logs so if you're
sitting on a beach
open up a cloud shell you can check the
status of your applications and
get it back to working
a final benefit of cloud shell is that
it's a
cloud based dev environment
so what does this mean for you cloud
shelves
include all the tools that you need to
be productive as a developer
so tools like git for source control
management
cloud shells typically include several
languages as well
so say you are a node developer you can
use
node right within a cloud shell
and finally cloud shells typically
include an editor so everyone uses or
knows of vim or nano
so you can actually edit files and
scripts and code
right within your cloud shell
environment
great so now let's step back a bit
and talk about what is a cloud shell
what are some of the building blocks
of a cloud shell
so first of all
at the base of what runs cloud shell is
a run time
or vm this is
what powers cloud shell at the lowest
level
next
is storage so
cloud shells may have either persisted
or temporary storage
persisted meaning as you go from session
to session maybe you log out
log back in you'll get your same
environment and same storage
temporary obviously is temporary so
it'll be
storage will be removed after some time
and finally you have the cloud shell
image
and this is what you interact with right
so this could be some
bash based shell
it includes your tools and
languages so this is what you actually
interact with on a cloud shell now of
course
all of this you access from a web
browser
so it's super convenient and always
available
something to note too about cloud
shelves is that they can either be
managed by you the user
and that means that you actually will
provide the runtime storage
and image so you can configure that
exactly how you want it
or a cloud shell can be managed
by the cloud
vendor
so what that means is they set up
everything for you right there's some
benefits of both
with the cloud vendor managed cloud
shell everything's already ready to go
and cloud shell runtime storage image
they already curate the tools and
languages that
are included can be really convenient
user manage can also have some benefits
too
maybe there's some security requirements
from your enterprise
about where storage needs to be located
so you can actually configure that
yourself
you can also configure exactly which
tools and languages you want to start up
with cloud shell
great so there's a few other features
that cloud shells could include
first one is web preview
what this is it essentially allows you
to preview
a port on cloud shell
similarly to how you do on your local
machine so maybe port 3000 or port 8080
when you're doing local development
you get that same experience but on the
cloud
the next feature of a cloud shell that
it may or may not have
is a gui based editor
now pretty self-explanatory this is
rather than a text editor
like a vimer nano it's actually a gui
where you can go in and edit files or
scripts
it may even have a debugger it can be
very useful when you're developing with
cloud shell
and finally cloud shells could have
file
upload or download so
also pretty self-explanatory it allows
you to actually upload files from your
local computer
to the cloud shell environment so that
if you go to somewhere else some other
computer or workstation you can see
those same files there
it also for file download you can take
files or scripts from cloud shell
environment down to your local machine
and continue development there if you so
choose
so that's what cloud shell is and those
are some of the benefits
as you can see cloud shell is a powerful
consistent environment
it's your own personal workspace on the
cloud thank you
if you have questions please drop us a
line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe
and don't forget you can grow your
skills and earn a badge with ibm cloud
labs which are free browser-based
interactive kubernetes labs